but first up he is the editor-in-chief
of Breitbart news be nice
Alex Marlowe is here hi Alex how you
doin oh thanks thanks for having me
because because you are the head of
Breitbart news Steve Bannon used to head
Breitbart news now he is Trump's
consigliere I want to say first of all I
want the Democrats to have a little bit
of what you guys are drinking because
you have balls and you fight better
you're here on my show I can't get
Democrats to come here Thank You Billy
it's a super high compliment and it's
one of the reasons why I'm here on the
show with you is because you have a
reputation of actually letting
conservatives speak their mind and speak
their full piece so compliments to you
hats off but I think that actually a lot
of our inspiration and Breitbart has
been following Democrats and people on
the Left over the years I'm from Los
Angeles I went to Berkeley I've
witnessed I live in Washington DC and
watching the left fight effectively
fight tooth and nail for their values
that's what Breitbart was founded on
those principles that we believe what we
believe so we're going to fight for them
with all we have oh wow I didn't expect
you to say that
I I don't think the left fights tooth
and nail they didn't even defend
Obamacare when Democrats gave Americans
health care not herpes okay anyway so
you're also honest about being a
right-wing organization which Fox News
is not okay but you do ignore stories
would you not agree to that I mean
Russia by design if I designed yes
that's honestly yeah yes and I try to be
consistent as we do at Breitbart news
and we're not going to cover the exact
same stories the exact same way as all
the other outlets we'll leave that to
the rest of the establishment press oh
we're very much anti-establishment
trying to highlight stories that we
don't think it's a fair day okay but
there's anti-establishment and then
there's anti truth if you're if you are
not covering Russia yeah you are not we
checked
it's kind of a big story I mean even if
there is no collusion it's still a big
story all of our intelligence agencies
which right-wing Patriots used to admire
yes they all say it happened you don't
cover it how do you justify that really
as I said if we don't cover it because
every other outlet in the world
particularly the left-of-center outlets
which are the vast vast vast number of
news outlets are obsessed with this
story covering it round the clock for
nine months the story really day not at
all Alex come on we cover it a little if
there's something big if there's
something that breaks that is a big
important story but we don't have any
evidence of collusion we don't have any
evidence no but we do option of just
with you yet but you would agree with
the 17 agencies I'm asking do you agree
that Russia did medal and try to fix
this election I AB Russia absolutely was
trying to interfere according to those
agencies I have no reason to doubt them
I have no Reno extra insight beyond that
but is this something that is news and
you think rush I'll trip the election I
don't know if I should tip the election
or not but we know that what they
release was true statements by Democrats
that were incredibly embarrassing and
it's the sort of thing with the
Democratic
well wasn't that enough to tip the
election if it was only 77,000 votes in
those three states well they did lose 20
30 states the Democrats lost 39 take a
look I don't know oh I'm not saying that
the Democrat I'm not saying the
Democrats don't have problems look look
at it this way you saw Titanic yes my
wife loves it I love it I'm ok with it
maybe I should be with your wife ok
looking and I'm saying the biggest in
Titanic there's a point with its spoiler
alert the ship hits an iceberg it's not
going to go well and the architect says
you know there's nine compartments below
if four of them flood were okay if five
of them flood were [ __ ] okay yeah so I
would agree there are many compartments
of this they had a bad candidate the
Democrats Hillary I think she would have
been a good president bad candidate the
electoral college is [ __ ] up it was a
year for the outsiders and liberal
sulking about Bernie and [ __ ] about
Hillary's the lesser of two evils that's
four compartments but come on Russia is
the fifth compartment you cannot claim
to me that they did all this [ __ ] with
the hacking and the emails and it didn't
tip the election there is no doubt about
it that Russia wants to sow discord in
the United States they want us to lose
faith in our institution but what's
happening with this story is it were
nine months in no hard evidence of
collusion if you present evidence of
collusion bill okay okay so guess I'll
even forget for you okay but in the
meantime I want to cover the President's
agenda more than I want to cover the
Russian let me read you nothing that
does not exist I'll get off this in one
second I'll just read what angus King
said cuz Jeff Sessions he testified this
week and angus King who I'm starting to
really love said the question he didn't
answer that really disturbed me have you
looked into what the Russians did miss
the Attorney General the United States
you asked for any briefings do you
understand the magnitude of what was
done to us and the answer was no he said
Comey essentially said the same thing
last week about the president they had
nine interactions never asked how the
Russians did it this is the most serious
attack on our country since September
11th and adversary is aiming in
at the heart of our democracy and these
guys are just shrugging it off it's the
commander in chief won't defend the
country against an attack by a foreign
adversary isn't that the most impatient
offense there is if the suggestion is
that it's impeachable because he hasn't
defended the country adequate since then
then I don't know what the precedent is
for that if there's collusion then we
can have the impeachment conversation
but there's no demonstrable evidence of
collusion and you guys continue to talk
about the story and the establishment
press instead of talking about the
president's agenda which is by design
because you guys won't apologize if it
turns out there's nothing no one will
come out on MSNBC it will just move on
to the next hysteria and that's a huge
advantage for people like me who are
covering the rest of the news I don't
think that's there but okay let's move
on to some let's go to free speech sure
because that's something we both care
about very much and I think it's under
attack from so many quarters in this
country you say you went to Berkeley
absolutely I didn't know that I was the
keynote speaker at their graduation a
couple ears I'm surprised they let you
on campus well they disinvited it they
did disinvite me okay and then there was
enough well there was not brought so
they disinvited me and then there was
another report so they reinvented me but
it's under attack on campuses it's under
attack by Donald Trump who threatens
reporters all the time and it's under
attack as I'm sure you know by
corporations there's this play going on
Julius Caesar
yes okay and there's a the guy who is
portraying Caesar is dressed as Donald
Trump it's plainly Trump red tied down
to his knee
crazy hair it's Trump and of course
Caesar gets stabbed now I'm fond of
saying to Republicans all the time if
Obama did it but really if Obama was
Julius Caesar and he got stabbed
I think the Liberals would be angry
about that oh absolutely it would be
bedlam in the media as the same thing
with the Kathy Griffin thing with
holding up president Trump's head with
blood on it which was not funny I mean
it's bizarre performance art uh
and I really do think this stamens funny
with with what okay not and III disagree
with that yeah I mean I think what it is
my president there is this I don't I
don't think they should have Trump
playing Julius Caesar and getting
stabbed I don't okay if a conservative
comedian did that with President Obama
would anyone say it was funny anyone
right one comedian so we're agreeing
that there are some places where free
speech does pause well it's bad strategy
certainly to put that out there
correctly all look like what hysterical
lunatics and so again helpful for
Breitbart not as helpful for the
Democrat but what about this thing where
corporations yeah now are getting in the
act and if you do something they don't
like they pull their funding yes
absolutely their address and I'll tell
you that this really started in my view
in the modern era with Breitbart where a
lot of people are boycotting Breitbart
and what they're doing is there's a lot
of anonymous people online cowardly
people we don't know who's funding them
we don't know who they are who are
putting out all of this misinformation
about who we are and what we stand for
and they're trying to round up
corporations to boycott us and so what's
happened is that corporations are now
deciding what's free and fair speech who
can make a living what opinions you can
make a living saying now and of course
now you're seeing the right fight fire
with fire and one boycotts of when the
left takes it too far in their Trump
hatred so it's a very dangerous path
we're on and I really do think bill and
I appreciate you giving me this
opportunity people on the left and the
right who are free speech advocates need
to come together right now and say the
corporations are not going to define the
First Amendment and free speech in this
country
yeah I mean I'm worried about Fritz also
under attack with religion I mean I
think now there are certain things about
terrorism that you and I do agree on
yeah I think criticizing a religion
whatever religion it is is not bigotry
in itself and I have to argue that on
the show all the time but come on Alex
you don't really think Muslim ban is a
helpful thing do you I mean that's a
stupid approach to the problem well
the stupid approach the strategy part I
think is interesting I think a lot of
where the ban comes from and again it's
not literally a Muslim ban it is only
highlighting countries that are not even
necessarily the countries that have the
most Muslims in their country but I
think the design is that people have
lost faith particularly the people in
the Trump inner circle that the
government has the ability to
effectively vet people coming in and out
of the country and until we do have
faith that they can vet people properly
there needs to be a Marine measure most
of the recent attacks have been from
people who have been here American
citizens so so yeah they got radicalized
somewhere they didn't get radicalized
exactly so what but not they weren't
coming from another country and there I
think a lot of it is that people don't
realize that American Muslims are about
four or five million people right and
and in the world it's a very different
situation it's a billion and a half
people and I don't think the problem is
here in America among American Muslims I
think we have to get them on our side
there's this ad I remember seeing over
Christmas remember the Amazon ad where
the Imam and the priest said to each
other knee pads yeah you remember that
yes yes you know and the idea is that
you know they're they're buddies and we
send each other knee pads to pray
because there are many ways to God and
one is not better than the other I think
that actually happens in America but I
don't think it happens in most of the
Muslim world I don't think the idea that
oh you know what there are many ways to
god they're all valid let's agree to
disagree I don't think that the thing
you find in Pakistan
right but I think it is true of America
so what can't we we get the American
Muslims on our side instead of
alienating them well you know I host a
national radio show for Breitbart and
Sirius XM every morning and I love
highlighting Muslim voices who are
progressive and reformist and want to
take out some of the misogyny and some
of the hatred associated with radical
elements of it and I think it's an
important place to start but to bring
back what Breitbart does different than
anyone else is we cover stories the
establishment press doesn't want to
cover for example many people don't know
that as many as half a million people in
the United States have undergone female
genital mutilation that's a story broken
in the USA Today
Breitbart highlights those types of
stories I don't see those stories on CNN
because I'm too busy hearing about the
latest non Russia story but okay the non
Russia stories are actual stories Alex
come on I'm having a little bit all
right
last question do you think Breitbart
with the politicization that it is
involved in has any responsibility for
the kind of violence that we see in our
society including what happened this
week absolutely not I mean as you know
that the guy was a big Sanders supporter
I actually happen not to blame Bernie
Sanders for it but when you have a
climate were you CNN for example calling
Breitbart the number one platform for
the Nazi salute over a video we never
played in CNN played when you have the
New York Times accusing Breitbart of a
putting racist dog whistles out when the
media lies so much about people calling
Trump supporters racist despicable
deplorable all of these things over and
over and over have been racist
despicable and deplorable okay
[Applause]
I mean the president I think has
retweeted what record it's absolutely I
encourage everyone to go to Breitbart
calm slash people you can meet some of
the Breitbart reporters you get the
Breitbart editors the most wonderful
diverse influential journalists on the
planet and no one is interested in their
real story because they're so quick to
want to call people racist and it's not
working that is why so many Democrats
are losing across the country they lost
thirty safely losing the governor shapes
the state houses and so if you want to
play that game bill if you want to keep
calling us racist I don't think it's
going to work for you so please have at
it when you do we will Alex thank you
very much for having the balls to come
there I do appreciate